all right michael we'll go ahead and get
started here
we'll open up for questions and let's
begin with mike singer mike go ahead
hey mike um the clippers had clawed back
i think it was 102 100.
ball finds you on the wing you hit that
three-pointer
what's going through your mind in that
moment obviously after a night where the
offense just
wasn't coming your way as much um
man it was i think yolk found me on the
wing
everybody know it wasn't the best shot
selection but some made me shoot it so i
shot it
it was really a god thing so it was it
was
it was a clutch shot but um you know
i'm just glad i could help my team in
that last couple minutes come away with
that dub
all right next we'll go to mark kizzler
mark go ahead
hey michael um let's let's go and
another few seconds after you make that
big shot
um you've been criticized for your
defense but you made a big block
and a big rebound after that um
at the defensive end how important was
that for you and for your team
yeah you know i'm just really just when
the game comes out of the wire
everybody got to be flying around so you
know my offense wasn't really flowing
tonight um but you know for me i don't
want to just be an officer player i want
to be all-around player you know like
you said i get criticized in
time for my defense but that's an area i
want to improve so when my office isn't
going you know i'm just trying to help
my team win in any way possible tonight
i just try to lock in on the defensive
end especially in that second half
right next we'll go to kendra andrews
kendra go ahead um
just the other day you said how
important it was to get
other guys involved especially when the
clippers are taking out
jamal and nicola so just i mean how
instrumental was that tonight to see
guys like paul stepping up you know you
down the stretch even monte morris
chipping in
and it's big time you know we we we
follow yolk and maul's lead
um and those guys came up so big in this
game especially in that second half
but you know i would say tonight sapp
won us that game we were down
and he kept clawing away he uh he played
physical
you know and he really helped clause
back in that game so
i was proud of the whole team tonight it
was really a team effort tonight and
we're still alive
all right next we'll go to dave
mcminiman dave go ahead
hey michael um your comments after game
four uh
received a degree of scrutiny including
from
a competitor or a dignitary in the game
and dame lillard
how did you process uh the way your
comments were perceived and
were they you know where they're on your
mind heading into this game tonight
no you know i try to i kind of try to
block that out you know everything i
said like
i stand by what i say um you know and i
didn't mean it in any type of
disrespectful way or anything like that
you know
the coaches and my teammates we they all
know that we we talked as a team
everybody was on the same page coming
into the day
um but you know damon those guys i
respect all those guys so
you know especially those superstars in
the league talking to a young guy like
me
you want to listen you don't want to
have an ego and just and think you're
always right um so i took what those
guys said and i listened to it
everybody has their opinion but um no
that was blocked out before today and
everybody was on the same page
all right next we'll go to joel rush
joel go ahead
hi michael uh going back to another play
um
on the fast break when you sent the
alley-oop up to mason plumley
is trying to do a little more playmaking
something you're working on yeah you
know for me i just
like i i knew early on like it might not
be my night offensively
um i only think i shot a few times
tonight so i just like like i said
earlier i was just trying to do anything
i could help the team win
um and i pushed the ball and you know
mace pg came up
and mace was on the rim he was playing
with a lot of energy uh tonight so i
wanted to reward him
at the rim and that was a big play for
us a big momento player
all right michael that will do it we
appreciate it man thank you thank
you